Hey
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us we know
that's true and today we explore how
music has a power to connect us all for
50 years the emmy-winning and
grammy-nominated Philadelphia Boys Choir
and chorale has captivated audiences
worldwide CBS this morning Saturday
co-host
Michelle Miller shows us one boys quest
to achieve his dream of making this very
elite and prestigious choir
Michelle were pulling for him good
morning oh I was pulling for him too
good morning from performing for the
Pope to singing with Pavarotti the
Philadelphia Boys Choir has a
challenging tour schedule and an even
more rigorous audition process for
months we follow along as ten year old
Gabriel Beckett competes to become one
of America's ambassadors of song and
this journey is about much more than
music it's September and 10 year old
Gabriel Beckett is auditioning for the
Philadelphia Voice Choir
[Music]
to make the cut he needs to master 12
classics including Philadelphia USA and
circle of life tribal feeling for the
past three years conductor and artistic
director Jeffrey Smith has been trying
to get him there these are the overall
issues now for each song and marked
specific things that you need to
practice Gabriel doesn't make the choir
this time but he's determined to try
again to understand his journey you have
to go back to the beginning this choir
has changed our lives when these men
were just boys this is the choirs very
first class we got into the choir it
just opened us up a whole new world a
grated you around the replaces and now
suddenly we are opened up to old
different cultures now Gabriel Beckett
has his chance if I make it it will
really feel like building my family is
solid what does that mean it means
feeling accomplished like making them
feel proud of me
his mother Tamika Becket sacrifices
working a full-time job at a supermarket
before shuttling him back and forth to
practice by bus train and subway
[Music]
and after a month of honing his voice
learning his music and controlling his
breathing Gabriel auditions again good
work a lot of time you put in all that
work is finally rewarded let's try a 10
he gets his signature red blazer the
iconic symbol that he's a member of the
choir that was the moment they actually
see what he was striving for I know my
mom has to struggle do a lot and earning
my lizard
I think really lifted her spirits it did
let's congratulate Gabriel Jordan
Beckett's this moment commemorated by
his family brings back memories for
conductor Jeff Smith
this is where it all started for me I
was 8 years old
this really shaped me and got me excited
about world travels and even here you
know hanging out and being friends with
kids from all different areas and all
different walks of life it really
develops these these kids into great men
as the men of the choirs first class
explain it it doesn't hit home right
away
to appreciate it but yet it's some dents
what mattered was that we sang the right
notes
[Music]
[Applause]
the choirs latest class is solidifying
that bond performing here at the kennel
center with the Philly Pops showcasing
the bonds of a new brotherhood based on
the traditions of the old what do you
think you bring to the choir yes
compassion excitement
and there will be much more excitement
in Gabriel's future this summer the
choir will go on tour in Italy it will
be Gabriel's first trip Abbar abroad and
in case you were wondering as of 2012
there is a Philadelphia Girls Choir and
I just have to say this uniting thing
really sticks because as I was going
through the archives looking through
pictures I came across this picture of
ukee Washington and Jerome Holland who
is the ambassador of sweet'n back then
in 1972 or 73 is it that she's gonna
anchor and he is the guy next to him
yeah it's my uncle I think that crazy I
thought that picture I was like oh
there's such a connection but I'm still
in awe where we all had died and his mom
the way they look at each other and what
he says he brings compassion excitement
you're just pulling for him and anything
that he does oh yeah I hope she goes to
Italy with him she deserves I know I
know maybe the under there and go fund
me I don't know I didn't ask that
question okay that's a good two down
here partying that out part two that's
why I would you to hold that means I
would have to go to Italy to write I
would like his mom to go think about
something Michelle